There are many common mistakes made when wearing heels, such as wobbly ankles,...
...stiff knees,...
...and gripping of the thighs.
Here are some tips to avoid those mistakes.
First of all, stand up straight, with your chest reaching to the sky.
This will give the impression of confidence,...
...as well as counterbalance the weight shift from wearing heels.
Secondly, engage the lower abs.
This will activate the lower back, which is helpful for stabilization.
And finally, relax through the hips and knees.
This will help you glide through the foot.
Alright, there you go.
That's it.
Chest up, lower abs in and relax through those hips and knees.
In no time at all, you'll be walking sexy and sassy.